please to meet this man I am a big fan
of just the way he went about his
business in the Academy award-winning
documentary free solo he's a
professional rock climber that everybody
around the world knows because we saw
free solo first ever solo ascent of
Yosemite 3,000 foot El Capitan without a
rope
couple of June's ago put to see you here
in one piece Alex Honnold thanks for
having good to see you so um so I very
rarely say this about guests I shook
your hand didn't feel very calloused at
all it seemed like you you got a nice
sort of non calloused hand does that
mean you're not climbing these days no
actually and people say that it's
because my whole hand is busy one callus
and that's sort of sort of ice and my
tips all the time is say my skin just
skin is pretty hard or not not really
yeah so you spend time just sitting
around and sanding down your hand yeah
using sandpaper to like trim all the
extra skin off your hand what have you
ever measured your hand because that's
in the NFL business a hand sizes is a
immeasurable never measured your hand no
and actually in for climbing you would
honestly be better to have a smaller
hand I think why because the actual
climbing holds are having an objective
size you know they say a 10 millimeter
edge you know like a like a quarter-inch
edge right you know this bigger your
hand is the smaller the edge feels
relative to your body no kid I mean so
if you have smaller fingers that I just
feel bigger because I would think you'd
need more gripping space for your work
well no it's going to sound like a total
idiot when it comes to talking about
rock climbing just so you understand I
don't know no no not ready well I mean
in basketball they call it the rock
shooting the rock I mean I have spoken
to the actor the rock but other than
that word you're kind of the first but
so I would think again that you'd need
to have more of a hand if anything
there's more mechanical advantage if
you're if you have smaller you know
smaller fingers say so so climbers often
talk about it as a one pad edge or a to
pet edge basically the pads of your
fingers like how big the edge is
relative to your hand right and so if
it's a two pad edge it feels quite big
just a lot of your hand is on it right
if your hand is really big
then you know everything feels small so
um what is what is the toughest thing
you've you've you've had to grip that's
not a rock
well actually the the clip we were just
showing that the boulder problem ah no
cap I mean a few of those holds are very
very small they're you know say
one-sixth of the the width of the edge
of my thumb you know I mean it's it's
really hard to apply leverage against
something that small so how do you do it
the world you do it well I mean the
thing is just to be clear you're not
holding your whole body weight off folds
like that you're using them as sort of
counter pressure between your feet so in
the case of the climbing on El Cap you
know I'm balanced on my footholds yes I
mean I'm pressing up into the hand holds
and sort of maintaining tension you know
with your core between you know hands
and feet do you work out at all no no
I'm just wondering if your rock climbing
does the is the exercise enough so
climbing is most of the exercise and
then I also do extra core workouts I do
you know opposition things like push up
something to you know maintain you know
healthy balance right because climbing
is all pulling muscles all the time so
sometimes you have to work the pushing
muscles separately just to make sure
that you don't over develop so the core
is basically your your lifeblood pretty
much yeah I mean so your legs should be
the thing driving you up a wall when
you're climbing and then your core is
what sort of connects your arms to your
legs so yeah I mean you have to sort of
keep them all
okay well all right so that's the how in
a way the why why do you do this
otherwise a large or - that's that's
different
why do you do this Alex what a basic
level because I love climbing I mean I
just love the movement of it I love the
feeling I like going climbing and then
if you mean the Y climb without a rope I
think that but we can get to that sure
we can get right down to it I mean I
think that has more to do with you know
sort of testing myself just understand
or I don't know it's a certain kind of
challenge you know it's a unique kind of
challenge I would say so that you decide
that I'm going to take on one of the
most remarkable physical feats anybody
could do where the penalty is death I
mean that's it that's all she wrote
pretty yeah yeah the thing is I am
taking on that challenge on my own terms
with my own timing after as much
preparation as I want so you know unlike
other sports it's not as if a coach
telling me like get in there and perform
you know it's up to me to spend as long
as I want and then if I don't think I
can do it then I never have to do it you
know and so really I'm seeking out a
challenge that I want in order to test
my own skills well I mean right now in
the NFL Antonio Brown one of the best
wide receivers in the game right now is
having an issue because the helmet that
he's always worn in the first nine years
of his career the NFL is saying it's
outdated outmoded he can't wear it
anymore for safety issues do you have a
piece of equipment that you're
superstitious about that you will not
climb without at all not superstitious
about but um but I can imagine you know
like my climbing shoes are probably the
most critical component you know
particularly when free soloing cuz
really it's the only equipment that I'm
using for player safety issues yeah
exactly right and so I mean if somebody
just told me I wasn't allowed to wear
the shoes that I'd always practiced in I
mean I would be a big deal right you
should have to sort of relearn Andry
practice everything using new equipment
well I mean professional golfers need to
use a putter or use right so what at
what point are you feeling comfortable
with the shoes that you how awful it
supposed to this way how quick how
quickly do you go through shoes but um I
can I wear through climbing shoes in a
handful of months I have been used but
none but I use the same model all the
time so at least I kind of know you know
I know how it wears over time okay and
for the hard free solos you have to have
a perfectly broken in pair of climbing
shoes that just the right state you know
and so for the free soloing I'll cap I
broken a pair of shoes right - and where
they were perfect and then that sort of
a shelved them for several months until
I was actually ready for the climb and
then the day before the actual free sole
I took them back out of the box and sort
of played with them a little to make
sure they still felt perfect how do you
do that like what's your process I just
did a little bit of bouldering with
really small edges so basically some
practice climbing with really small
footholds to make sure that the shoes
felt perfect on the footholds it's just
and what about the clothes you told me
something backstage yeah the clothes I
just wore I wore the same clothes for
all the practicing and then for the
actual time just because I wanted
everything to feel exactly the way it
had when I practiced I mean I assume
that's the same with all sports right I
mean people well I mean I need to
clarify the same exact shirt or same
makeup sure know the same sure yeah but
I mean to be
I was living in a van and I'm awash you
know you just wear the same shirt so
yeah I mean you know hygiene wasn't on
steroids by myself in a car I mean who
cares
are you Alex Honnold here on the Rich
Eisen show are you still with the same
girlfriend yep girlfriends on it a
couple of her yeah I know she's a very
very tolerant woman okay so where are we
right now with you and your girlfriend
usually ask personal questions in people
but I mean we've that was a very crucial
part of the documentary
yeah a big part of the film and and yeah
and she's a big part of the whole film
tour with me which was also sort of an
incredible experience right and now
we're just back to living a normal life
to living a normal life to another okay
which is very nice actually
okay that's great did you and what did
you meet at the Oscars oh I mean yeah
everybody is crazy
give me drops drop some names come on
now I know you don't like to drop names
no I'm her she like shook my hand going
up on stage for the Oscars yeah and then
afterward reelected her Jolie just shake
your hand and then there's this classic
anecdote later one of the after parties
because he was going by with this whole
suite of security
yeah I saw me I just grabbed a bunch of
little snacks from the buffet thing and
then she saw him at her show was about
to turn to her to introduce and she was
like cause he threw all the snacks on
the floor he's like hey I'm Sonia I'll
charming like shook his hands so great
to meet you and then he and his his
suite of security walked away and she
was like I gotta pick up all my snacks
you gotta get your hands empty if you're
gonna shake those shoes this is my
chance he's so handsome that's well I
mean this is this is great I mean so are
you going to the Emmys also yeah yeah I
think so okay no are you gonna wear some
more North Face down I'll wear whatever
I'm told to wear why why why don't you
climb something like the set with Joey
at the Emmys yes I I don't like to climb
things but I'm gonna get in trouble you
know I don't wanna get arrested on Alex
Alex Alex if you climbed at first of all
they don't have a host so they're free
soloing the program has no no host which
as a host by the way be careful Alex
it's okay it's alright we're without a
net right now there's no ropes right now
there were
host so who's gonna stop you offered
maybe you should I have Alex I have no
I'm just a sports guy
so you're just a climber right bad
sports to the Emmys I think so so vitam
Singh first of all there's no host so
who's gonna stop you and - that would be
the most amazing part of the Emmys if
all of a sudden like in the middle they
spotlight you and you're up there I mean
can't be that tough to go up it's
probably not that tough but um you know
it's just it's a little gimmicky and
then you want her and then you wind up
detained and then you know what you're
right Alex Honnold you're right gimmicky
entertained I just you know playing
around so um before I let you go what
what's next are you planning on doing
where are you now I know that was a
question for you in this documentary is
next where are we now two years later
about next basically still just just
climbing all the time see you know you
know new climbing challenges they'll be
and you seventy of the season working on
a new route on El Cap but I've a
climbing with a rope climb with the
partner just uh you know we'll see you
about future big solos you know just see
how it plays out so you're gonna go back
to the same spot in Yosemite yes I've
spent maybe three months a year for last
12 years in Yosemite always always
trying to climb new routes and challenge
myself in different ways and so I just
continue doing that and kind of see
where that leads me another question I
have for you how do you get down in on
El Cap you can do actually run down the
side it's kind of a big broad shoulder
so you can kind of run down
what do you mean run well you walk down
I guess but I ran it's funny Chris Alex
sat down he goes how long is your show
every day I said three hours man that's
a long time and I'm like okay it's only
56 minutes shorter than the amount of
time it took you to free solo 3,000 feet
so it's it's I mean that's nuts yeah so
you did you hold on a second you went up
El Capitan without a rope in three hours
and 56 minutes and then and then ran
down yeah it's like 45-minute run back
down I think that day was the fastest
I've ever made it back down I was so
over psyched I basically like sprinted
down but man if I did that I would camp
up there I would have a snack
absolutely yeah you know I know you have
you've got the powder behind you
wow what a snuck at least a candy bar or
something up there I had some snacks the
camera guys brought snacks that's part
of the beauty of making a film is that
the guys can bring you snacks what do
you mean so you're hanging you're
hanging there and you took a free hand
to just have small there are camera guys
on the summit as well but now Manila I'd
stash food and water on the route into
places so I did to get to take little
breaks at about 1/3 and 2/3 higher hold
on a second walk me through this what do
you mean you stash snacks so there's
some ledges on I'll cap about the size
of your desk let's say okay they
relatively big ledges so they're places
that you can sit down pop your shoes off
relax for a second so I took little
breaks here in there cuz you kind of
have to pace yourself throughout the
climb I would think so and so yeah so I
you know ate and drank a little bit in a
couple places so what do you mean you
stashed it like when you went up with
rope oh yes during the preparation I've
just left it clipped your nacre so I
just like what what you have what you
have I left one liter of water on both
ledges and then I left a couple little
like I think a little Clif Bar you know
energy bar type things with like little
sugar block okay just basic you know
technicals nice go ahead you ask the
question you said in my ear Chris go for
it
did you have to go to the bathroom at
all while you were doing this yeah yeah
I peed off the wall much times I mean
that's totally normal part of climbing
just peeing on the rocks
well I'd occur to see you pee off the
rock Oh for somebody who's free soloing
that is that would be a courteous thing
is that you just not do that
yeah you just don't want to make it you
know no because so many people climb El
Cap and people camp on the wall people
spend four days climbing the wall and so
the main ledges like the places where
people can you wind up smelling like
urine because if everyone pees on the
wall oh sure so but so but it would be
also courteous to make sure you don't
take somebody else's food or water
that's stashed right yeah yeah yeah
mm-hmm so that's what you did you add a
little bit and then you ran down yeah
walked I would have to seriously I just
stopped how maybe had some s'mores or
something seriously well no but my well
think of it is my home is you know right
below me so I just run down how my
normal lunch you know you know talk to
my friends it's pretty exciting you know
you just wanna I'm sure you were bossing
I mean I cannot I just cannot imagine
inaudible experience alright ask the
poll question of Alex Honnold before we
we leave here we obviously know one that
he might not answer but ask the poll
question go for it ask him yeah yeah
Alex what an honor of you being here
yeah another of you being here what's
your biggest fear Heights spiders snakes
public speaking I would say it used to
be public speaking definitely when I was
younger and publicly was horrifying I
think now if I had to choose between
those that say the spiders are my least
favorite thing or maybe snakes I don't
know they're equally you know or the I
don't like them were there any on on El
Capitan sometimes but not on the
particular tree solo I don't think so
but um but yeah in general when you
comment I'll cap you definitely see like
big you know especially a nighttime huge
centipedes come out of the wall know
that uh and you know frogs and mice and
things like that frogs yeah they're
really cute little frogs that go up
there huh yeah they all live inside the
cracks okay
yeah it's El Capitan frogs does anyone
ever try to talk you out of this stuff
yeah yeah all of my friends think it's a
bad idea if you've watched the film I
mean you know there was some pretty
serious conversations with the camera
crew and with a lot of my climbing
partners about whether or not it's worth
it one member of the crew couldn't watch
his cameras trained his job is to be
having a camera trained on you from the
ground up he couldn't watch yeah look
yeah it's it's it's a tough thing to
watch for sure yeah is it a tough thing
for you to watch no I think it's great
but when you were watching free solo
it's not like at one point you go oh
gosh even though you obviously know
because I remember how I felt and so I
know that it was I was perfectly
comfortable and that all was an
incredible experience but I think if I
was watching one of my friends do the
climb I think I'd find it Zoey unnerving
as well I would think slightly unnerving
would definitely one win one way to put
it
a man Congrats on everything that's
going on with you before I let you go
let's talk about the Honnold foundation
and Honnold foundation org is how you
can help get involved with what you're
doing Oh even sporting solar around the
world last long time basically it was
just my attempt at supporting
environmental projects yes and then
wound up gravitating toward solar
because it helped human lives more but
um so you're building solar energy
putting solar in people's homes we've
done some things abroad with just solar
lanterns
lighting villages that don't have access
to electricity hmm but like right now
we're working on the first cooperative
solar micro grid in Puerto Rico that's
basically putting solar panels on a
bunch of businesses in the community and
for a cooperative micro grid it's just
you know different projects turn places
but just an attempt at doing something
positive for the environment that helps
people well I look forward to the sequel
do you think there's gonna be a sequel
free song - I doubt there'll be a free
soul I honestly I think the crew is too
stressed to make sure the crew did an
amazing job and absolutely deserved the
Oscar for Best Documentary and I hope
they sweep every last Emmy nom that they
have and that you enjoy send my best to
your your girlfriend she is definitely
as you say a saint just sitting out
there and rooting for you and you know
that phone call comes and it's I'm sure
she loves hearing your voice you know
thanks for coming on this show you got
an Alex Honnold on both Twitter and
Instagram free solo check it out the Nat
Geo documentary wherever you possibly
can it is amazing downloaded iTunes
Amazon Prime Google Play YouTube Vudu
Xbox Fandango and I'm at geo TV a fan on
demand you can basically see it any time
you want good to see you sir thank you
you got it for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR Live or download
the Rich Eisen show app